Microsoft is already partnered up with  oculus but will be getting even more  features on the Xbox one soon  I'm Tony and this is your virtual  GameSpot news update Xbox one is getting  an oculus rift app this will allow you  to pair up with your console and stream  games to the headset think psvr  cinematic mode but with more detailed  environments of course this doesn't  suddenly turn games like Gears of War 4  and Forza horizon 3 into VR titles but  instead creates a virtual theater  experience still it'll be cool to  literally see your games through a new  lens the oculus on Xbox one app will be  available December 12 Microsoft's  partnership means every oculus headset  already comes with an Xbox one  controller and runs natively on Windows  10 so we'll likely see more  interactivity in the future to keep up  with all the latest news on Xbox and VR  you're already in the right place